oh I love these capri pants take me to
the first moment that you actually got
to see the fruits of your Labor's on
screen we had just finished up a session
write a voice session and they was like
hey we're gonna show you guys the movie
and they took us to a theater on like
the Sony lot and yeah it was just me and
Jake we have food and it was a really
lovely day we got to record together a
bunch we've done a lot of press here so
we got to we've been able to hang a lot
than being able to watch that movie and
see it which was really nice when it
ended we both kind of looked at each
other and neither of us said anything
for a while because visually it's so
stunning that it's like nothing you've
you know they told us it's like nothing
you've ever seen before but a lot of
people say stuff like that yeah sure
this really was it was like nothing I'd
ever seen before
you know honestly Phil Lord and Chris
Miller who were the origins of this
story and then the directors Bobby Peter
and Rodney and all the animators did
such an intense job with the animation
and the story and there was so much care
to it that you know I've never I've done
animation before but this one was just
different we've been recording for two
and a half years and we would record in
the booth together and then they would
animate around performance and then we
could do things and they would change
things and then you know we could also
change around the animation so this was
something that they really worked really
hard on and I'm very happy to see people
loving it and celebrate it because every
time we would go into record the
directors wouldn't be like you know
upbeat and energetic they all had bags
they were working with sure and so this
has been you know it's been an exciting
one to watch the response yeah I mean
you guys could just if you wanted to
take this opportunity to just list all
the other superhero movies that can suck
it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
on a serious note I think it was crazy
because at first even Chris and Phil and
so many people like at the beginning of
the when we were taking interviews and
stuff at first people are like well why
do we need another spider-man or what's
the point of you know what why exactly
what do you think that they're gonna do
you know to make this one special and
okay okay let me also say something else
it's not one or two or three I'm talking
about I've seen at least six or seven
six or seven like hardcore critics say
this is the best part of that spider-man
ever to this point you know I'm saying
in his animated you know
so all these seven eight other movies
that y'all was referring to before y'all
saw this movie you know I'm saying that
was a great segue I didn't say it you
can you can fast-forward and rewind and
it's all been said because like what
would it have meant to you to see Miles
Morales on screen like as a ten-year-old
I mean the same way I felt when I saw
him when I was 14 on screen it was like
whoa he's black you know and I'm the
type of person that I don't I grew up a
certain way with I don't really seek
color in a way where it's like you know
this this character is white so I don't
like double-oh-seven or I don't like
Harry Potter
I don't like jogging Ball Z or Peter
Parker or I don't I didn't even think
that I didn't relate to them either you
know not until somebody else told me I
didn't relate you know and that's
because I look at I like acting in
movies and stuff as art you know I never
looked at these movies and said I would
never be on TV because I don't see any
black people on TV I never thought that
way you know but when I saw Miles
Morales for the first time I was out oh
he's black you know I'm saying it that
that is the point of representation and
you know I get what I'm the position
that I'm in it's like it's very special
and I'm not the only one we you know
we're in a new time but it's it's a I
forgot how even better it is really
special yeah it's really cool it's also
really cool to have you know spider-gwen
in the movie do you know as a father of
two daughters way
I first told him I was in spider-man
they were light younger they would go
around those and call themselves
spider-man girl and I was like I don't
mean to be a dick but there's just not a
character named spider-man girl right
but but it's like yeah but you actually
can be spider-gwen and if you were you
know african-american and Latino and you
didn't relate to Peter Peter didn't feel
like you you know miles might be closer
was there a previous version of
spider-man that that kind of you carried
with you in any certain way while you
were creating your characters from the
movies or the comics like either for me
for Peter it was more because this is
Peter at 40
this is Peter Parker past the early
years of being a superhero and past the
peak of it and it's kind of what it
means to have you know lived your dream
and then what happens to your life after
that so my only real reference point was
the idea of Peter and those early comics
and what you know when I was a kid and I
first heard about it and the whole idea
is that he's just a regular guy who got
bit but the whole point is Peter's a
regular guy so this version that they
wrote is you'll see you know obviously
he's a very regular guy uh-huh he's more
regular than we've ever seen that's
right with that said nothing but respect
to the previous spider-man we're not
coming in looking to create any trouble
with the spider-man franchise yeah
spider-man's done pretty good we're just
happy we're just happy to be here with
this movie happy to be a part of it but
we're starting to get hit with that a
lot where they're like people are saying
it's the best one what do you think it's
like well I think so too and I'll speak
for both of us we're really happy yeah
tell me what other character in the
spider verse of yours you'd like to see
get a spin-off and why it's about
anymore that would be a cool spin-off I
think
spider Gwen and I think she's getting a
spinoff but I'm excited for the you know
female spider-verse to see what that's
all about I hope Peter and Miles can
find their way into that one I would
like to see you know more of that that
female representation I think would be
pretty cool and not just
for the idea of representation and blah
blah blah but in terms of the freshness
I think was really cool in our movie
when she pops in I've never seen a lady
spider
spider-man girl I've never seen it so
I'm like what is that whole universe
look like there this movie proves that
there's still room for new
interpretations and new things to be
said that's right and that's what's
great about it
now speaking of Spyder noir I know that
you guys sometimes recorded voiceover
together yeah
did you ever record voiceover with Nick
Cage no but I actually asked and I said
I would find myself to Vegas and they
said that's just not happening but I
wanted to be even if the recording was
like in his house and like a weird
basement I'm like wherever NIC cages do
it whatever Nick Cage is doing I want
two hours of that I feel like especially
if it was in his basement it's like if
he's like I'm recording this like back
shed and let's go to the back shed my
man's awesome I don't even care if I
murdered back there I lived pretty good
up to the moment whatever Nic Cage would
offer I would say yes to he's like I've
got this weird appetizer sure whatever
it is I'm eating and pretending it's
great you wouldn't even wait for him to
eat at first I'm going for it if it's
poison kill me Nic Cage let's get weird
I want to experience all of it but I was
a I was told he's doing something that I
was thinking about when I was when I was
coming up with questions for this movie
is just that whole idea voice over is
fascinating to me you know you're having
to pretend like you're actually doing
things in the moment all right so like
the action
yeah like the action is happening and so
I actually kind of wanted to just like
test out on the fly because I know you
guys are good at this if you could say
something like a completely benign
sentence but do it like you're doing
another action so like if you said like
I like hamburgers but say it like you
just burned your hand on the stove okay
so you'd go like I like hamburgers yeah
Bravo or like if you were like if you
said I love you like you were falling
off the edge of a building
yeah okay now I get this game it took a
little bit even when I did Emily they
might be doing the nod like I did it
wrong and everyone's being polite but
yeah we're doing it right
what about I love these capri pants okay
can't say that contractually I'm against
it
god I love these capri pants like you
were learning how to fly for the first
time well we're talking about spider-man
spy minute a fly fighter meant the whips
of what about a first swing okay at
first wing oh oh oh I love these capri
pants okay you get a lot of Tanks
together yeah you got a surprise okay
okay what about your shoelaces are
untied when you see a terrifying monster
[Laughter]
I'm learning so much in a serious thing
about that the fun thing about being
able to record together is we actually
got to act at the scenes so if I had a
line and it was somebody from the
recording thing who said your shoelaces
are untied
well they would be doing it like your
shoelace is untied and then you've got
to do everything around it what made
this one special is I'd never been able
to do voice over with other people and
they would let us do full scenes so you
get to just act for a scene and then
they would record and if you missed a
line they would pick that up but I think
that's one of the reasons why a lot of
the performances feel more like
three-dimensional and it's like we got
to act he got back with Brian I got to
act look at like we had different people
we got to record with it does make a
difference a lot and especially for
everybody said in the audience yeah
totally it's cool when I was watching
this I couldn't help but love and miss
Stanley yeah
and I was wondering if you guys had kind
of a recollection or anything about him
that you could share with us well I
didn't unfortunately I didn't get to
meet him I would have liked to but what
I really learned about Stanley and doing
all this and doing press with you know
real diehard comic-book fans which I
can't consider myself one even though I
like the world but hearing how much
people truly loved him I've actually
learned what spider-mans originally
about and how it's about anybody and you
know the theme of our movies obviously
anybody can wear the mask but I didn't
realize that was Stanley's kind of thing
and that when he created Peter Parker it
was a really weird thing that he was a
regular person who became a superhero
and at that time that was a
revolutionary idea and so this idea of
ordinary people can do great things if
they put their mind to it and they work
hard I think is a great message that I
didn't realize was his but I've realized
throughout and I have you know I wish I
would have met him so I could say good
job Stanley he had a life he did pretty
good here yeah I would just say you know
I appreciate being a part of his
ultimate vision you know and I look at
Stanley because I think in a way where I
think about the hundred years like my
full story you know so everything that I
do all the projects I take and
everything I put out even when it comes
to like posting things on social media
and stuff is just like everything needs
to be forward like the bigger purpose
you know and so I'm writing stories like
I'm not just talking about not not
playing or or I'm not just saying hey we
don't need to be you know
double-oh-seven we should create our own
double-oh-seven I'm actually writing
that project for myself with my team you
know what I mean like I'm I have these
plans for my next ten years and whatnot
I I do use that journal you know and so
seeing it be successful with Stanley and
knowing that that imagination helped
change a lot of my life at this moment
you know what I mean
this is years later he just passed and
that's very sad but like he just made he
he passed it on and I hope that I can
follow that that uh that guideline that
outline you know what I mean one nice
thing about Stanley is he has been
celebrated for a long time so it's not
one of those guys who you know all this
a lot of times people died then everyone
talked about hug right thereafter nice
thing about somebody living a full life
is he knew also what people thought
about him which was a really nice thing
yeah so it's sad
and he his ideas live on
you
[Music]